The following content is
proved under a Creative Commons
license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today we're going
to talk about privilege
separation, so we're done with
buffer overflows at some level,
but will keep
coming back as being
a problem that we
want to deal with,
so we'll not talk about the
details of how to exploit them,
now we'll switch more into
mitigation, if you will,
or prevention techniques of how
do you design a system where
buffer overflows aren't such a
huge problem for you, perhaps,
as well as other
security vulnerabilities.
So for today we're going to
talk about privilege separation
as a general purpose
technique for how
to build a more secure system,
and the particular paper
we assigned for you today is
this web server called OKWS.
It's not necessarily the biggest
example of privilege separation
on there, but it's a reasonably
well described system
that we can actually read
and really understand
how all the pieces work,
and you should really
think of it more as a
case study of how to do
privilege separation right.
Not necessarily you should
go and download OKWS
to run your website right now.
So before we dive into
the details of OKWS
and Unix permissions,
let's just see
what is privilege separation,
why is it such a good idea?
And then, last
week's lecture, James
showed you that if you
write a program in C,
then it's almost inevitable
you'll have something bad
go wrong in that
program, and the problem,
at some level is that if
you have a large application
and there's any kind
of all vulnerability
in this application, then
adversaries can connect
and send requests
for this application,
might be able to trick
it into doing bad things.
And the application is
presumably privileged,
meaning there is probably
lots of data sitting
behind the application that
it can access and maybe delete
files, like you guys
are going in Lab I now,
read sensitive data,
install back doors.
And the problem is
that a vulnerability
in this large
application can allow
it to modify any of
this data, or basically
exercise all of the privileges
this application has,
and it probably has
lots of privileges,
unless you're careful about it.
And what privilege
separation tries to do,
and what we'll look
at in this lecture,
is to take the
application and chop it up
into different
pieces and make sure
that each piece has only
the necessary privileges
to do its job correctly.
So you could imagine
maybe all the privileges
you care about are access
to data in the back end,
then all of this data, maybe
you can slice it up in some way,
give this access to
this piece of data,
this piece access to this
piece of data, and so on.
So then, if you find a bug
here, then maybe this data
is kind of compromised,
but hopefully
whatever slicing
you've done is going
to enforce the separation
so that a vulnerability here
doesn't allow the
attacker to go and access
these other pieces of
data, or, more generally,
other privileges of the
application has access to.
So this is the big idea
behind privilege separation,
and it's hugely powerful.
It actually doesn't really
rely on buffer overflows
or other kinds of
vulnerabilities being present.
It's just a general
architecture for making sure
that vulnerabilities
in one place
don't affect as much as
possible your system.
This turns out to be
used pretty widely.
Virtual machines often are
used for enforcing isolation
within components.
Maybe you'll take
your large system
and break it up into a
bunch of DMs for isolation,
but you could also use
Unix to actually perform
this isolation with slicing.
And as we'll talk
about in a second,
Unix does provide you quite
a number of mechanisms
that OKWS does actually use to
achieve privilege separation.
And then many
applications actually
use privilege
separation practice.
You guys are probably
using SSH quite often.
That uses privilege separation
in many of its components
to make sure its
keys are not leaked
and the server doesn't
get compromised
or the effect of our server
compromise is reduced.
And perhaps more relevant to you
guys, Chrome, the web browser,
actually does
privilege separation
quite extensively as well.
So that if there's a bug
in Chrome's implementation,
the adversary doesn't get full
control of your computer, which
is a great property to have.
So that's just a
very quick summary
of what privilege
separation is about
and why maybe OKWS is an
interesting case study.
I guess we can add
it to this list,
but it is more of an
illustrative example
rather than an important piece
of software in its own right.
Make sense?
Any questions before we dive in?
All right.
So OKWS, as I
mentioned, it's going
to use Unix permissions
and sort of Unix mechanisms
to achieve the
separation between
its different components.
So as a result, it's
going to be important
for us to understand how Unix
protection mechanisms work.
And Unix isn't in some
way crucial to OKWS
at some level for
privilege separation,
but for any isolation
mechanism you're
going to use, whether it's Unix,
uid, these other mechanisms,
or virtual machines
or containers
or any other technology, it's
really important to understand
the details of how the
isolation mechanism works,
because there's a lot of
tricky pieces to get right,
because you're dealing
with some attacker that
can exploit any [INAUDIBLE].
So as a result,
we'll look at Unix
in a fair amount of
detail just to see
what it's like, how
should we approach
thinking about a particular
security mechanism.
Let's look at Unix.
So Unix historically-- well,
it's not necessarily the best
example of how to build
a security mechanism,
because its security
mechanism came about
from a fairly utilitarian
need of needing
to separate different users on
a single Unix system from one
another, so they
weren't thinking
of it as a general
purpose mechanism
that applications
like OKWS are going
to use to implement
privilege separation.
They're just thinking,
we have a bunch
of users that are using
the same computer,
we need to keep them
from each other.
So it's not necessarily a
general purpose mechanism
but still one that is fairly
prevalent and, as a result,
widely used.
Chrome tries to use many
if these Unix mechanisms.
So what does Unix have?
So, in general, when you're
thinking about protection
mechanism, you should
be thinking, well,
what are the principals, meaning
what are the entities that
have privileges or rights,
and in Unix these principals
are typically invoked, or
sort of held, by a process.
So I guess the subject, if you
will, in Unix is a process, so
every operation or request that
we can think about in terms
of security, whether something
should be allowed or not,
is probably going
to be an operation
that a process invokes
by making a system call.
And the principal is
how we describe what
privileges that process has.
Conversely, there's also what
we can think about as objects,
and these are the
things that a process
might act on that try to modify,
read, observe in some way.
There are actually a
lot of different kinds
of objects you might worry
about protecting in an operating
system.
What do you guys think?
What should we worry
about protecting?
AUDIENCE: Files.
PROFESSOR: Files.
Yeah, great.
That's a big one.
That's where all of
our data lives, right?
There's a closely
related thing we
might worry about-- directories.
Turns out to be
pretty important also
from a security standpoint.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Networking sockets.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, great.
Networking sockets.
Anything else going on?
AUDIENCE: Other processes.
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
Actually, this is like
stuff that the application
or the user might care
about, but then there's
all kinds of internal stuff that
you have to protect as well,
so a process is not just the
subject that's making a system
call, but a process
is also something
that another process
can act upon.
It can kill it or
create a new one.
You have to figure out, what
are the rules for thinking
about process as an
object you can manipulate.
Other things we
might care about?
AUDIENCE: Environment variables.
PROFESSOR: I guess
they're probably
not an entity you can
modify, in the sense
of being managed by an iOS and
having some sort of a security
policy.
I guess I sort of think
of environment variables
as just being some state a
process maintains in memory.
But, I guess more
generally, we do
care about maybe
part of a process
is all this stuff in memory.
So there's going to be
environment variables there,
there's a stack,
there's arguments,
and this also turns out
to be quite important.
Presumably lots
of sensitive data
lives in processor's memory.
Other things?
AUDIENCE: File
descriptors in general.
PROFESSOR: There's like
another sort of internal detail
that matters a lot.
So files are the stuff we
might care about on disk,
and there's this operational
thing, the file descriptor,
that OKWS makes quite
extensive use of,
and we'll see what
file descriptors are
in a little bit.
Any other stuff you guys want to
protect in an operating system?
AUDIENCE: Hardware.
PROFESSOR: Hardware?
Yeah, I guess in many
ways hardware is-- well,
hardware is, in some ways,
not really an abstraction
that the iOS provides to you.
I guess you run
a process, so you
might want to make sure
the CPU doesn't get stuck.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah, yeah.
So, like, extra
devices, Yeah, you're
right, especially on
a desktop machine,
there's lots of extra stuff.
So there's your USB drive you
plug in, your webcam, probably
your display itself is something
you'll want to protect,
like an application shouldn't
draw all over your screen
anywhere.
So, yes, actually I
guess this isn't really
on a server side view of
things, where there's just
a server somewhere in a
closet, but on your phone,
your microphone probably,
is a hugely important object
that you want to protect,
yeah, but I will also leave it
off this list,
because we're going
to talk much more about
server applications for now,
but you're absolutely right.
I think for OKWS,
this is probably
a more or less
exhaustive list of things
we might care about protecting,
or, at least that OKWS uses.
So let's talk about
how does the OS kernel
decide when a process
can do something
to any of these objects?
So the [INAUDIBLE], I guess is,
we mostly think of a process
as having the privileges
represented by this principal,
and the principal
in a Unix system
is this slightly
complicated thing.
There is something
called a userid,
which is just a 32-bit integer.
There's also a group ID, which
is also a 32-bit integer.
And there's not really a great
reason why they're different.
It would've been nice
if they were just
a uniform set of 32-bit
integer principal numbers,
but unfortunately Unix
sort of splits them
into two categories.
There's userid integers and then
there are group ID integers.
When we talk about a process
having certain privileges,
we typically think of a
process being associated
with a particular uid value.
The process, for the most
part, has a single uid.
As with almost
everything else, there's
complications
everywhere in Unix,
but I'll simplify it for now.
A process has one
uid, and there's
also a list of group
IDs that a process has.
For historical
reasons, the group IDs
are split into one and
then a list of others.
Roughly, a process
can then exercise
the privileges represented
by all of these identifiers.
So if there's something
accessible to this userid
a process can do stuff with it.
That's how we think about
what privileges a process
has, so now let's talk
about files, directories
and other kinds of objects.
So what happens with files,
or how do Unix permissions
for files work?
Well, in Unix, every
file has-- actually,
maybe a better way to
start is to think of what
operations do we care about?
For files, things are
relatively straightforward.
For files, you probably
care about read, write,
maybe things like
execute as well,
change permissions, maybe change
other security properties.
AUDIENCE: Unlink.
PROFESSOR: Unlink.
Well, so is unlink a
property of a file itself
or is it a directory thing?
Actually a little not clear.
At least, the way Unix
thinks of deleting a file,
is that it's really a
directory kind of thing,
because in Unix you can have--
a file is really an inode,
and in Unix you could have
multiple hard links to an inode
and when you unlink a particular
name of a Unix file, what
you're really doing is killing
one of the names for that file,
but it might have other
names, other links to it.
So what actually
matters is whether you
are allowed to modify the
directory pointing at the file
and not do something to
the file's inode itself.
So typically, unlink
and link and rename,
create, are operations
that we sort of think
of as being associated
with the directory,
although, they are actually
related, so "create" affects
both the directory and
a new file as well,
so we have to figure out
what are the rules there.
OK, so what are the rules?
In order to help us decide
when someone can read or write
a file, we're going to stick
some permission stuff, or bits,
in the file inode.
In Unix, every inode,
meaning something
that ends up being
the file or directory,
has a couple of interesting
fields for security purposes.
There's a userid and a group
that we say owns the file
or owns the directory.
So you might have all the
files in your home directory
are probably owned by
your on your Unix system.
There's also a set of
permission bits in Unix
that you can sort of think
of as a bit of a matrix,
so we want to have-- well
in Unix there's basically
the basic design,
there's read, write
and x for execute permissions.
We can specify these permissions
for different entities,
and in Unix these are
specified for the owner,
meaning for the
uid of the inode,
for the group that owns the
file, this gid and everyone
else, other.
You can sort of fill in
this 3 by 3 binary matrix.
You might say, well, I can read
and write and maybe not execute
this file.
People in that gid might
be able to read but not
write this file, and
everyone else-- or maybe they
can also read it-- but not
do anything else with it.
So this is the way Unix
stores permissions.
There's some baroque way
of encoding these things
that you'll see often that's
probably worth mentioning.
In Unix, you encode this
matrix as an octal number,
so you treat each row here as
a base 8 number, so r is bit 4,
w is bit 2, x is bit
1, so this ends up
being 6, 4, 4, so you'll
sort of say-- well,
you'll often see this
notation, even in this paper.
You'll say, well, this
file has permission 6, 4,
4, meaning the owner can
read and write this file,
the group owner can read it and
everyone else can also read it.
Does that make sense?
This tells us when you can
read, write and execute a file.
What about changing
permissions on a file?
This is not entirely a fair
question, but what do you
guys think?
How should we
decide when someone
should be able to change
these permissions,
because that's also something
to try to do, at least.
Any guesses?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If they
have [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Maybe, yeah.
It depends.
On the other hand, you might
create a overwritable file
that I just want to share
with anyone, that you
can read and write
and modify my file,
but then this also means
that you'll all of a sudden
be able to change
permissions, so you'll
be able to take my file and
make it not overwritable
or take it over.
That seems not
necessarily great, so
in Unix, what are
the designers chose,
is that, well, if
you own the file,
meaning if you have the
same uid as the file,
then you can change permissions.
Otherwise, you cannot.
So even if you're in the gid
here and that group has all
the permissions in the file,
you still cannot really change
the permissions on that file.
You can just read,
write, execute,
whatever to get that solved.
Make sense?
Then directories
actually in Unix
follow a pretty similar story.
So unlinking and linking
entries in a directory
means having write
permission on that directory,
and if you want
to rename a file,
then you probably need
to have write permissions
on both the directory
you're moving it from
and the directory
you're moving it to.
A fairly natural plan.
There are some corner cases with
hard links, as it turns out.
Lecture notes have some
details but, more or less,
that's how it works.
There's actually another
interesting operation
on directory that you might
care about, which is lookup.
So you might want to just
look up a file in a directory.
And Unix sort of encodes
execute permissions
as implementing lookup
for directories,
so what it means to have execute
permissions on a directory
is just being able to look
up a certain name there.
Might be that you don't actually
have to execute permission
on a directory so you
can look up a name,
but you don't don't
have read permission,
so you can't list the
contents of a directory.
It turns out to be
useful in some situations
if you really want to
restrict what someone
could do with those
files, or sort of hide
the files from a user.
Let's just work
through an example.
What happens on Unix if I
call open("/etc/password")?
What checks is the kernel
going to perform on my behalf
when I issue this system call?
AUDIENCE: It checks whether
you have execute permissions
on etc?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that
will happen somewhere.
I need to execute on etc.
AUDIENCE: And then
execute on slash.
PROFESSOR: Yes, actually, I need
to look up what does /etc even
point to?
So if I don't have look
up permissions on root,
then that's not going to work.
AUDIENCE: Then you need
read on /etc/password.
PROFESSOR: Make sense, roughly?
Here's a small puzzle.
Suppose that MIT sets up a group
for all the people associated
with 6.858 and another group
in the Unix sets of gids
for all the TAs at MIT, but they
don't have a group four 6.858
TAs for some silly reason.
Could I create a file that's
only accessible to 6.858 TAs?
If I have a 6.858 group,
or some gid, and a TAs gid.
So there's only one gid
that I can stick in a file.
Any guesses?
AUDIENCE: Well, you couldn't
anyway because you might
have TAs that and not 858 TAs.
PROFESSOR: That's true, yeah.
Suppose they want to--
you're right, yeah,
so there are students in 858
that are TAs of other classes,
so that's maybe not great.
But, still, lets try to
do intersections somehow.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, so you
can actually play tricks
with this mechanism.
It's not perfect,
but you can sort of
use it to encode more
interesting things.
You could actually do something
like create /foo/bar/grades
file, and what I'll do is
I'll actually make foo owned
by-- or set the gid to 6.858
and only make it executable
for the group.
So unless you're in this group,
you can't even look things up
in /foo, and then I could
set the permissions on bar
so the gid is for TAs and
then it's executable for group
as well and not others.
So unless you can actually
traverse this path,
you can't get to
this grades file.
It's kind of, you know,
a cute hack, if you will,
but these kinds of
tricks are things
you end up doing with whatever
the base primitives are,
the isolation mechanism
provides to you.
And even OKWS plays all these
tricks as well in their design.
Make sense?
Questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If, like, the
permissions on the grades
file itself, were let's
say-- the QID was 6.858,
could a TA, like, link it
to some other directory
and allow anybody in
6.858 to access it?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
potentially, right?
So you might worry about
other things like leakage now,
so Unix in general
doesn't try to enforce
these kinds of transitive
security properties,
meaning that once a process
has access to some data,
or has some privileges,
it can basically delegate
those privileges
to anyone it wants.
There are other kinds of systems
called mandatory access control
systems.
We'll perhaps talk
about them later,
but those try to
actually enforce
this transitive property that,
if I give it to you, then
you can't give to other people.
You're basically stuck.
It sort of taints you and
you can't go anywhere else.
In Unix, this is
generally not the case,
and a TA probably could not
hard link this file because
of another silly rule that Unix
enforces for hard links, which
is that only the owner
of a file can hard
link it somewhere else.
And this is partly
because of the way
Unix does quotas,
because in Unix quotas
are by who owns the file.
So if you create
some giant file,
I can hard link a copy
over to my directory,
then you maybe delete the
file, but I still have it,
and the file system thinks,
yep, that's the owner,
but you can't even
delete it, because I
have the reference to it.
So that would be a bit of
an unfortunate combination
of Unix mechanisms there.
But in general, you should
worry about such things
like transitivity,
like could someone--
or maybe a better problem
is, maybe someone was a TA
and then we remove him.
But maybe they can still sort
of stash away a reference
somewhere, so this is maybe
not a perfect solution
for this problem
for many reasons,
including the fact that
there's non-858 TAs taking 858.
Are there questions?
OK, so that's files and
directories in Unix,
so how security works for them.
A closely related thing in
Unix are file descriptors.
The file descriptors are used
fairly pretty widely in OKWS
and what a file descriptor
represents in Unix
is basically an open file.
So in Unix in
particular, it turns out
that the security checks on
opening a file are performed--
or security checks
for accessing a file--
are performed when you open
the file in the first place.
And from there on, you
have basically a handle
on the file, where
anyone with that handle
can now perform
operations on that file.
So the rules for basically
accessing a file descriptor
are, if you have an open file
descriptor in your process,
then you can access it.
And security checks
don't apply in the sense
that, to get that
file descriptor,
you could have just opened
the file, in which case
these regular checks
would have applied,
or some other process
might have passed the file
descriptor to you, so you
can pass file descriptors
by inheriting from a
parent, so a parent
can pass a file descriptor
to a child process
or you can pass file descriptors
through sockets in Unix,
but however you manage
to get a file descriptor,
you can read and write the
file descriptor all you want,
because the security
checks have already
been done when the file
descriptor was initially
created.
So that's actually
a nice way in Unix
to give someone privileges
that they don't otherwise have.
So in OKWS there's probably
many components that
need to act as a
certain socket or file,
or whatever you
have it, and one way
to implement this without
giving them direct access
to read and write the
file in the file system,
is to have someone else open the
file, create a file descriptor
and then pass it to
this extra component.
This way, you can
really precisely say,
that's the only file
descriptor you'll ever have.
And there's nothing
else they can
try to do in the file
system that might be funny.
Make sense?
So in fact, it has fairly
simple rules, I guess.
If you have a file
descriptor, you
can do whatever
you want with It.
OK, so what about processes?
What are the rules there?
I guess, what can
you do to a process?
In Unix it's fairly simple.
You could, I guess,
create a process.
You could kill it.
You could debug it.
There's this mechanism
called ptrace in Unix,
and probably a couple
of other things.
And the rules are
relatively straightforward.
So you can always create
a process, more or less,
except that the child
process is going
to get the same userid as
you, so you can't create
a process with some other userid
by default. So you can't say,
well, I'd like to
create a process running
as "web," one of my TAs.
The operating system kernel
will not let you do that.
If you want to kill a
process, you basically
have to have the same userid
as that process as well.
It's kind of nice.
All the things with
a single userid
are isolated from things
with other userids.
And more or less, the same
rule applies to ptrace as well.
The process with the same
uid can debug processes
with the same uid.
As with everything, it turns out
race conditions show up often
and can cause
problems, but there
have been actually
some interesting bugs
in the ptrace mechanism in Linux
where, if you debug a process
and then it switches and gets
more privileges, then maybe you
could somehow trick the
kernel into letting you retain
this debug privilege
on this process,
even after it becomes
more privileged.
Then you can monkey with
its memory and take it over.
But at least the basic
design that you probably
want to enforce is roughly
a process with the same uid
can act on each
other, otherwise not.
And I guess, OK, so what else
did we have on this list?
Processes.
Memory sort of goes
along with the process.
So, unless you're
in that process
you can't access
the process memory.
Virtual memory nicely enforces
this isolation for us.
Except this debug
mechanism lets you
poke in another
process's memory if you
happen to have the same userid.
And then, I guess the
other remaining thing
for us is networking,
and networking in Unix
doesn't really fall
in the same model,
partly because of
it came about later.
You know, the Unix operating
system was designed first
and then networking came
along and became popular.
It has a slightly
different set of rules.
So I guess the operations
we really care about
on the network is, presumably,
connecting somewhere or maybe
listening actually for
connections as well.
So you might want to
connect to some web server
or you might want to run a
web server yourself and listen
on a particular port.
Maybe you want to actually
read data from a connection,
or read/write data on
some existing connection,
or you want to send the
raw packets or receive.
So in Unix the network
stuff basically has
no relation to userids,
the first approximation.
The rule is anyone
can always connect
to any machine or
any IP address,
can always open a connection.
If you want to listen
on a port, that's
where one difference
shows up, which
is that most users
are prohibited
from listening on ports
below a magic value of 1024.
Basically, if you listen and
the port is less than 1024,
then you have to be
a special user called
"super user" with a uid of 0.
And in general, Unix has this
notion of an administrator,
or super user, which is
represented by having uid of 0,
which can bypass pretty
much all these checks,
so if you're running as root,
then none of this applies.
You can read/write files,
you can change permissions
on anyone's files and
the operating system
will let you do that
because it thinks you
should have all the privileges.
And one thing you
really need it for
is for listening on
ports below 1024.
Any idea why this
weird restriction?
Who cares about
your port number?
AUDIENCE: Would they define
specific port numbers
to be certain things,
like HTTP is like 80.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
like HTTP is 80 here.
On the other hand, other
services might be above 1024,
so why this restriction?
Why is this useful?
Seems to complicate my
life more, after you.
AUDIENCE: Since you don't want
random searches just listening
on your HTTP.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
I think the reason
for this is that it
used to be the case,
at least, that you'd
have these machines where
there's lots of things running,
there's users logging in,
there's services running,
and you want to make sure
that some random user
logging into our machine doesn't
all of sudden take over the web
server running on that machine,
because people connecting
from outside don't really know
who is running on that port.
They just connect to port 80.
And if I want to log
into that machine
and start my own
web server, then I
would just take over all the web
server traffic to that machine.
That is probably
not a great plan.
So this is one way that the
networking subsystem in Unix
prevents arbitrary
users from impersonating
what are called well-known
services running
on these low port numbers.
So that's sort of one
rationale for this restriction.
And then, in terms of
reading and writing data
on a connection, well, if
you have a file descriptor
for a particular socket, then
Unix lets you read and write
any data you want on that
TCP or uTP connection.
And then for
sending raw packets,
Unix is actually pretty
paranoid about this,
so it actually will not
let you send arbitrary
packets over the network.
It has to be in the context
of a particular connection,
except if you're
root, of course,
then you can do
whatever you want.
That make sense?
Somewhat?
Any other questions about
all this Unix machinery?
OK, so one interesting
question we could try to ask,
is where do these
userids come from?
So, when we talk about
processes having a userid
or having a groupid, and if
you run PS on your machine,
you probably see lots of
processes with different uid
values.
Where do these guys come from?
We need some sort of
a mechanism really
to bootstrap all of
these userid values,
and the way it works in Unix,
at least at the mechanism level,
is that there's several
system calls for doing this.
So initially to bootstrap
these uid values,
there's a system called setuid()
that you that you can pass some
sort of a uid number to,
and it'll set the userid
of the current
process to this value.
This is actually a dangerous
operation, of course,
so in sort of Unix tradition,
you can only do this
if you're uid is equal to 0.
Well, must have.
So if you are this
root user with uid 0,
then you can call setuid() and
switch your user to anything
else.
There's a couple
other similar system
calls for initializing the gids
associated with the process.
It's setgid and setgroups.
So these system
calls together let
you configure the privileges
that a process has.
So typically, when you go
and log into a Unix machine,
the way that your processes
get the right privileges,
is that you're
initially actually
not talking to a process
running as your uid,
partly because the system
doesn't know who you are yet.
Instead, what you
initially talk to in Unix
is some sort of a login
process, so maybe SSH
runs a process for anyone
that connects to it
and tries to
authenticate the user.
So this login process runs with
uid=0 as root and then when
the supply username
and password,
it's actually going to check
it against its own database
of accounts and,
typically in Unix,
this get stored in two
files, /etc/password, which,
for historical reasons, no
longer stores the password.
And there's another
file, /etc/shadow,
which does store the password,
but in /etc/password,
there is actually a table
mapping every username
in the system to
these integer values.
So your username gets mapped
to a particular integer number
in this /etc/password file, and
then login will check whether
your password is correct,
according to this file,
and if it is, it'll find your
integer uid and then call
setuid on your uid value
and then execute your shell.
Whatever, (den/sh) And now
you can actually interact with
the shell, but it's running as
your uid so you cannot do any
arbitrary damage
to this machine.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Is it possible to
start a new process with uid 0
if you have some non-0 uid?
For example, if you
want [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so this sort of
lets you go down, if you will,
so with your root, you
can restrict yourself down
to a different uid, but
the rule we set so far
is you can only create a process
with the same uid as yourself.
But, of course, you want
to elevate your privileges
for various reasons.
You want to, I don't know,
install a package now
and you need root privileges.
So, Unix has
basically two ways you
could think about doing this.
One way we already
mentioned, this file
descriptor passing thing.
So if you really want to
elevate your privileges,
maybe you can talk
to some helper,
and the helper is
running as root.
You can ask it, hey, can
you open this file for me?
And maybe you like define
some new interface,
and that helper opens the
file and gives you back
the file descriptor
through fd passing.
That's one way you could
elevate your privileges,
but it's kind of awkward,
because what you really
want in some cases is a process
running with more privileges.
So in order to do this, Unix
has this sort of clever,
sort of problematic mechanism
called setuid binaries.
So setuid binaries are just
regular executables in a Unix
file system, except
that when you run them,
when you sort of co-exec on a
setuid binary-- one example is,
for example, is /bin/su on
most machines, or sudo as well.
There's a bunch of setuid
binaries on a typical Unix
system.
The difference is that when you
execute one of these binaries,
it actually switches the
userid of the process
to the owner of this binary.
It's a little bit of a weird
mechanism when you first
see it.
Typically the way it is used
is that this binary probably
has an owner uid of
0, because you really
want to regain lots of
privileges-- you want to regain
root privileges-- so you
can run this su command,
and the kernel, when
you exec this binary,
will switch the uid
of the process to 0,
so this program will now
do some privileged stuff.
That make sense?
AUDIENCE: If you
have uid 0 and you
change the uid of all
of those setuid binaries
to something non-0 and then
you could start [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, many
processes will not
be able to regain
privileges later.
You might be kind of stuck.
It'll still boot probably,
but maybe some things
will not work.
This mechanism is
not tied to uid 0.
In fact, "I" as a user on a Unix
system can create any binary.
I can build some
program, compile it,
and I can set this setuid
bit on that program itself.
It's owned by me,
the user, my userid.
And what this means is,
anyone executing my program
will run that code
with my userid.
Is that problematic?
Should I do this?
AUDIENCE:So, if there was
a bug in your application
and suddenly someone
could do anything as you,
not just with the program
that's assigned to you.
PROFESSOR: Right.
But yes, so that's right.
If my application
is buggy, or if it
allows you to run
anything you want,
well, I could copy
the system shell
and make its setuid
to me, then anyone
can run a shell
under my account.
That would probably not
be a best plan of action.
But a system mechanism,
well, this is not necessarily
problematic, because the only
person that can set the setuid
bit on a binary is
the owner of the file,
and owner of the file
has that uid privilege,
so I can basically give away
my account to other people if I
want, but someone else cannot
create a setuid binary with
my userid.
That make sense?
And the setuid bit
is sort of stored
alongside these permission bits.
So somewhere there
is also a setuid bit
in every inode that says whether
this executable or this program
should be switched to the
owner's uid on execution.
Does that make sense as sort
of a privilege estimation
mechanism?
It turns out that this is
a very tricky mechanism
to use correctly.
So the kernel
implements it correctly.
It's actually a fairly
easy thing to do.
It's just one check.
If there is [INAUDIBLE],
switch the uid.
Easy enough.
But using it safely turns out
to be very tricky because,
as was just pointed out, if
this program has bugs in it
or does something
unexpected, then
you might be able to do
arbitrary things uid 0
or whatever the other uid is.
And it turns out in Unix, the
way you execute a program,
you inherit a lot of stuff
from your parent process.
For example, you can pass
environment variables
to the setuid binaries, and
it used to be the case that--
well, in Unix, you can specify
what shared library should be
used for a process by setting
an environment variable,
and it used to be that the
setuid binaries weren't careful
about filtering out these
environment variables,
so you could run
bin/su, but say, well,
use my shared library
for things like printf(),
so your printf() is going to
run when bin/su prints something
out, and you can get it to run
a shell instead of printing
stuff.
So there's many
other subtle things
that you have to get right
in terms of this program
not trusting the user
input, and this is actually
quite different
from how you think
of writing most Unix programs.
You generally do trust
the user input a lot,
so for this reason,
the setuid mechanism
hasn't been the most
secure part, in some sense,
of the overall Unix system.
All right.
Any questions about this stuff?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does setuid
apply to groups as well,
or just the user?
PROFESSOR: There is actually
a symmetric setgid bit
you could set.
Why not.
And you could-- well, the
same thing happens, right?
If the file has a particular
gid and that setgid bit
is set when you run the
program, you get that group.
It's not used a lot, but
it is useful in cases
where you want to give
very specific privileges.
So here, like bin/su probably
needs a lot of privileges,
but it might be that
there's some program that
needs a little bit
of extra privileges,
like maybe to write something
to a special log file.
So you probably want
to give it some group
and make that log file
writable by that group.
So even if the program is
buggy, which is likely the case,
then, well, you lose
that group, sort of,
privileges but not much else.
It is sort of useful
as a mechanism,
but it doesn't show up often,
because it's-- I don't why.
People should use root more.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What are the
restrictions on who
can change the [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Different Unix implementations
have slightly different checks
for this.
The general rule of thumb
is, only root can change
the owner of a file,
because you don't
want to create files
owned by someone else,
and you don't want to take
over other people's files,
of course, either.
So, in general, if you're
a particular non-0 uid,
then you're stuck.
You can't change
owner of any file.
If you're a root, you can
change it to anything you want.
There are some complications
if you're a setuid binary
and you switch from
one uid to another--
it's a little bit tricky--
but for the most part
you basically can't
change the owner of a file
unless you're a root.
Make sense?
Other questions
about this machinery?
It is, admittedly, a
slightly baroque system.
You could probably imagine
lots of ways in which you could
simplify this but, in fact,
most successful systems sort of
look like this as
they evolve over time.
As it turns out, you
can make some good use
of these sandboxing mechanisms.
These are just sort of the basic
Unix primitives that show up
in pretty much every
Unix-like operating systems,
so Mac OS X has this, Linux
has this, FreeBSD has this,
Solaris-- if anyone's
still runs this, et cetera.
But in every one of these, there
is actually more sophisticated
mechanisms that you
might use, so Linux
has something called set COMP
for sandboxing processes,
Mac OS X has its own
thing called Seatbelt,
and there's all
kinds of extensions.
We'll at one extension actually
next week, just to see,
but this is just to get you
familiar with the basics
that every Unix system has.
So one sort of last
bit of machinery
we want to look at
before diving into OKWS,
is how do you deal
with setuid binaries?
How do you protect yourself
from these security holes,
if you will.
So the problem is that
inevitably you'll have some
setuid binaries in your
system like /bin/su, or sudo,
or what have you, and there's
probably bugs in these
programs, so if someone can
execute the setuid binary,
then that process
might get root access,
so you don't want to do that--
or don't want to allow that.
The mechanism in
Unix that is often
used to prevent a
potentially malicious process
from exploiting
setuid binaries is
to use the file system
namespace to modify it,
using the chroot system call.
OKWS uses this
pretty extensively.
So in Unix, what you can
do is you can call chroot
on a particular directory.
So maybe you can chroot("/foo")
and there's actually two
explanations I want to
give to what chroot does.
The first one is just intuitive.
What it does is it means
that after you run chroot,
the root directory or slash
basically is equal to what /foo
used to be before
you called chroot.
So it kind restricts your
namespace down /foo so it looks
like that's all
the stuff you have.
So if you have a file that
used to be called /foo/x,
after calling chroot, you
can get at that file by just
opening /x.
So just restrict your namespace
down to a subdirectory.
So this is the
intuitive version.
Of course, in
security, what matters
is not the intuitive version,
but what is the kernel exactly
doing with this system call?
What the kernel does is
basically two things.
So when you call chroot
a particular directory,
it does two things.
One, it changes
what slash means,
so whenever you access--
whenever you start a path
name with slash, the kernel will
now plug in whatever the file
you gave to chroot.
It's roughly the /foo file
from before you called chroot.
The other thing the kernel does,
is it tries to prevent you from
escaping out of your / by doing
/../ because you could imagine
in Unix, I could ask for, you
know, give me /../etcpassword.
So if I just prepended /foo,
then this would not be good,
because I can just sort of
walk out of /foo and go get
/etc/password.
So the other thing
the Unix kernel does,
when you call chroot, is
for that particular process,
it changes how it evaluates
/../ in this directory,
so it basically changes /../
in /foo to point to itself,
so it doesn't let you do
this kind of escaping,
and this change only applies to
this process and not everyone
else.
Does that roughly make sense?
So do you guys have
any ideas about how
you could escape a chroot
environment because of the way
it's implemented?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if
you're [INAUDIBLE],
you can make a directory and
then bring that directory,
and then go back to your
directory and [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So, the interesting
thing-- so the kernel
only keeps track of
one chroot directory.
And I'll explain sort of the
answer that I gave in a second.
So what you could do is,
maybe your chroot'd into /foo.
You're sort of stuck.
You want to get
at /etc/password,
but how do you do it?
Well, what you could
do is you can actually
open the root directory now.
That will give you a file
descriptor for effectively what
is /foo.
Then you could
call chroot again.
Maybe you can chroot into /bar.
So now the kernel changes plan.
Root is no longer /foo but
it's /foo/bar and this /../
redirection only
applies to /foo/bar/..
But know that you still have
the file descriptor for /foo.
So now what you could do is
you could change directories
into that file descriptor,
fchdir(fd) from this open call,
and now you chdir(..) And at
this point, you were in /foo,
you go to /../ from foo.
It's no longer looped
back to /foo itself,
because you now have a different
route and now you can escape,
so this is perhaps a good
illustration for why the exact
mechanism matters a lot.
It's not, sort of, the intuitive
explanation that matters.
And partly as a result,
in Unix only the root user
can invoke chroot,
because otherwise chroot
would be fairly
pointless, in some ways.
So in Unix, you basically
have to have uid 0 in order
to chroot a process.
It's a little bit of a
disappointment in some ways,
because if you wanted to
build a really privileged
separated system
where everyone had
just the minimum set of
privileges necessary,
you would probably
need to use chroot,
you would need to create
new userids, et cetera,
but in order to do
that in Unix, you
have to have a process
running as root,
which has lots of privileges.
So it's a little bit of
an unfortunate trade off,
but it's probably one you could
make some reasonable design
decisions on.
Question.
AUDIENCE: If in the [INAUDIBLE]
directory, so [INAUDIBLE]
to a file that's in [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No, actually,
unless you do this trick,
the kernel evaluates symlinks in
your root context, if you will.
So if you have a symlink
to /etc/password,
it'll evaluate as if it is
similar to /foo/etc/password.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: A hard link
would not be protected.
Yeah.
So one way to set up a chroot
environment without creating
lots of copies of
files is to, in fact,
create a directory and hard
link all these things back.
That's fairly cheap
and then use it.
AUDIENCE: If a program gradually
generates inodes and, like,
actually not to give you
the file descriptor--
PROFESSOR: Right.
So it's like a huge
important detail here, is you
can only access a file by
path name, not by saying,
I want to open inode number 23.
This might be some weird file
out there outside of my chroot.
So in Unix you cannot open an
inode by inode number unless
you're root, of course.
Other questions?
All right.
So I think we have sort
of enough machinery
now to see what these
OKWS guys do, and probably
a useful, quick
introduction is by contrast
to what everyone else does.
So what is it that everyone else
is doing that the OKWS guys are
afraid of?
So the alternative design
that pretty much every web
server follows, is like the
unprivileged separating picture
above there, so you might
have web browsers out there
on the internet, these guys are
going to connect to your server
and, inside of your server,
you're basically going to have,
basically one process, httpd,
well, Apache, let's say.
And this is one process running
as a single userid called www
in /etc/password.
It takes all your
connections, does everything
with your process, including
doing SSL processing maybe,
including running
application code and PHP,
et cetera, all part
of the same process.
And if need be, this process
will typically connect back
to some database
server, maybe MySQL
could be running on
the same machine,
could be running elsewhere.
And this MySQL process
actually writes data to disk.
But to connect to this
MySQL, you probably
have to provide a
username and password
but, typically, the way
applications are written
or, at least, not very security
conscious applications are
written, is that there's a
single account on the MySQL
server that the application
knows the username and password
for, so you just connect
and you have access
to all of your data.
So it's super
convenient to write,
because you just write
whatever code you want.
You can access whatever data
in the database you want.
There's no real
isolation, but it
has security problems that
these guys worry about,
namely if there's bugs in
Apache, maybe in SSL, maybe
in the application code
or in the PHP interpreter,
then inevitably the answer
is, if there's a bug
and you can exploit
it, then, yep,
you get the whole
application data contents.
Does that make sense?
You had some questions before.
No?
AUDIENCE: Oh.
Uh, yeah, it's fine.
Thank you.
PROFESSOR: All right.
No worries.
OK.
So this is sort of state of
art what these guys really
wanted to protect against.
And in their case, I guess they
worried a lot because they were
thinking, well, they're building
basically a dating website,
okcupid.com and
they really wanted
to make sure their,
I guess reputation,
wouldn't be damaged by
these data disclosures.
So in fact, I
guess-- from talking
to the guy that
wrote this paper,
it seems like they actually
haven't been compromised--
or, at least, not
that they know of--
or their data wasn't leaked.
And it seems to be partly
as a result of running OKWS,
partly as a result of maybe more
proactive monitoring that they
do, et cetera, but it seems
to have worked out reasonably
well for them, to
some extent, I guess,
because of this
architecture that we have.
OK.
So the reason that
people, I guess,
don't break up their
applications into smaller
components is
because it actually
takes quite a bit of effort to
separate out all their pieces
of code and define clean
interfaces between them,
decide which data
every component
should have access to, or
if you decide to implement
new feature, you're
going to have
to change the data that every
component has access to give it
new privileges or take
some away, et cetera.
So it's a bit of some overhead
for separating application,
but in their case I
guess they decided
it was worth the effort.
Let's try to understand how
their web server design works,
and perhaps one way to do
it is to trace out roughly
how http request gets
processed by an OKWS server.
So, similarly to
that picture, there's
probably a web browser
out there somewhere
that wants to go to
okcupid.com, and in their design
they sort of imagined
they're going
to have a bunch of machines,
but we'll just look at probably
just one front-end
machine that is
going to be running OKWS
here and then another machine
behind the scenes
that's going to be
storing the database somewhere.
And I sort of imagine they're
probably also using MySQL,
because it's a nice piece
of software in many ways.
They don't want to re-implement
this functionality,
but they want to really
protect this data, so
that it's really hard
to get to the raw disk
or the raw database.
So how does a
request work, or how
does a request get
handled by OKWS?
Well, the request
first comes in and gets
handled by this
process they call
okd for the OKWS dispatcher.
So those guys look at what
the request is asking for
and then actually
does a couple things.
So first it might need
to log the request,
so it forwards it to this
component called oklogd,
then it might need to
generate some templates,
maybe before the
request came in even.
And this is handled by
another component called pubd.
And finally, there's
a particular service
that this request
is being sent to,
so okd has a table of a bunch
of services it supports.
This request is presumably
going to one of them,
and, as a result, okd
will forward this request
to a particular service process.
And the job of the service
is to actually do something
with this request,
like subscribe
the guy to a newsletter
or to match him
to whoever else is using
OkCupid, using the database.
And in order to do this,
the service presumably
might need to log some
information about the request
as well by talking to
this oklogd component.
And at the end of the day it's
got to talk to this database.
So the way these
this guys actually
implement talking
to the database
is that, unlike that Apache
picture where you just
talk to the database and
issue arbitrary SQL queries,
these guys come up with this
notion of a database proxy that
sits in front of
the MySQL database
and accepts requests from the
service to do some queries,
and I think that's most
of the picture for OKWS.
There's another component
in this whole picture that
sparks this whole mess, so
they have another component
called okld, for the
ok launcher demon,
and this guy is responsible for
starting all these processes
on this front end
web server machine.
Hopefully some of
these things actually
look familiar, because
this is exactly
the architecture of [INAUDIBLE]
for your lab assignment,
so this is basically what
our design is all based on.
It seems like a nice
design, actually.
Well, we don't
have pubd or logd,
but we have these two
guys and a service.
No database proxy either.
All right, so any
questions about OKWS?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Dbproxy does
not accept SQL queries,
it accepts some sort
PROFESSOR: Yes.
What does this
interface look like?
They don't really describe
it in a lot of detail,
but one thing I sort of imagine
you could do in this database
proxy is basically
have this supply
a bunch of arguments
for SQL query templates.
So it might be
that this dbproxy,
this one in particular,
maybe is for finding,
I don't know, your
friends or something,
so inside of the
dbproxy maybe there's
a template query like select
ID from friends, where user-- I
guess this is like
the ID of the friend,
and this is the ID of the
person who is the friend of.
The user equals, I don't
know, person D here,
or something, or
person S here, right?
And they sort of
sanitize this string,
and I imagine this RPC
request here sort of looks
like do query one, and the
argument is, I don't know,
"Alice."
I sort of imagine this
RPC interface looks
like this, where the
application knows ahead of time
that this database
proxy is willing to run
three kinds of
queries on its behalf,
and now I want to
run query number one
and the argument is Alice.
And that's sort of
the way I get access
to any data in the database.
Does this make sense?
AUDIENCE: Could an external
user at the web browser level
send the request like
that to the database
or is that all internal?
PROFESSOR: Well, yeah.
So, how does this work?
It's actually kind
of weird, that this
is a separate machine,
because now it seems like,
why don't just connect to
the database proxy yourself,
or to the MySQL server, right?
So what prevents
this in their design?
AUDIENCE: Fire wall?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
probably at some level.
They don't really describe
this in too much detail,
but probably this is some
internal network, where there's
like a switch here,
and this machine
is connected to the
switch, this machine
switch, but the switch
is not reachable from
the outside world.
It's like there is an
internet connection here
and those guys are
some back-end network.
Or maybe they're actually
on the same network,
but there's a firewall here that
has rules that say, well, you
can only connect to this
front-end machine on port 80.
You cannot talk to
the back-end server.
So that's one plan.
I guess the other
plan they have in mind
is that actually when you
connect to this database proxy,
you have to supply this
20 byte token thing,
and unless you supply
it, the dbproxy
will reject your connection.
So the rule is you open
the TCP connection,
you send your 20 bytes.
If they're not the
right 20 bytes,
your connection gets
closed, and hopefully this
is something that's relatively
easy for the database proxy
to implement, so
that there's probably
low probability of a bug in
that token checking logic that's
right up front.
And unless you
have the token, you
will not be able to do
anything else of interest
to the database server.
That's, I think, their
sort of design goal here.
Make sense?
All right.
So, let's try to
figure out, I guess,
how these guys isolate
these different processes.
So how do they make sure
that all these components
don't trample on each other?
What's the plan?
AUDIENCE: Different roots
and different userids?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so pretty much
every one of these components
runs as a difference uid, so
they have this whole table
in the paper that describes,
for every component,
where is it running
and what's the uid.
So we can write this out,
so okd has its own uid,
pubd has its own uid, the
logger has its own uid.
okld runs as root, which
is kind of unfortunate,
but may be all right.
Then, there's a whole bunch of
dynamically assigned userids
for every service.
I sort of imagine
he has ID 51001.
So this makes sure that
every service cannot poke
at the processes
of other services,
and they also use chroot
pretty extensively,
so every one of these guys is
chroot-ed into some directory.
They sort of initially
say, well, you
should really chroot everyone
into a separate directory.
As it turns out,
in that table, it
turns out that okd
and all the services
basically share a
chroot directory.
It's kind of weird.
Why do you guys think they
put okd and the services
into a single chroot and not
give them their own chroots?
Weird.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: okd is not root.
PROFESSOR: Well, yeah,
but like why don't they
put pubd and oklogd and
everyone else in the same
chroot as well?
AUDIENCE: Okld [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: okld is
actually sitting out here
in a separate chroot.
This guy, this guy.
Actually okld is not chroot.
I'm sorry about that.
These guys are chroot.
Does it matter?
AUDIENCE: I was thinking,
if the services have
to share a lot of data, where's
the [INAUDIBLE] isolate them?
PROFESSOR: Maybe.
Actually, I think
what's going on
is they have to share some
data, but none of this data
actually lives in the file,
so they pass a lot of data
through sockets from
okd to the services.
But in fact, none of these
guys store anything of interest
at all in the file system.
So as a result, there's pretty
much nothing interesting
in the chroot directory, so
I imagine the OKWS guys just
decided, well, there's
probably some overhead
to creating a
chroot, like you have
to create a copy
of the directory,
there is maybe some management
overhead for every chroot.
Whereas, for this, there's
no real files here,
so maybe that's all right.
I mean, there's not
a clear, sort of,
cut trade off here, or
not a clear-cut argument
which way you should go,
but certainly prevents
from setuid binaries.
The reason that these guys are
probably in different chroots
is because there is actually
some interesting stuff there.
There's maybe the
templates here,
maybe there's a log
file here, so you
don't want these guys
accidentally reading
the log file for some
reason, but there's
no real mutable state
inside of the chroot shared
by all okd and the services.
AUDIENCE: Don't the services
have, like, two files
or, I don't know, aspx files.
PROFESSOR: Well, at least
the way they describe it
in the paper, the service is
a single C++ compiled binary,
so there's actually no extra
files, and there are templates,
but those actually get passed
in through this weird mechanism,
where pubd has the
templates in its directory,
it renders them-- or sort
of pre-computes them--
sends them to okd and okd
gives the templates to all
the services through RPC calls.
So they sit in memory,
but they're actually not
directly accessible
through the file system.
It's a somewhat
paranoid design here.
Can't even read the templates.
So what's the point of having
all these components split up?
So I guess let's talk
about maybe oklogd,
so why do you have
a separate oklogd?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because if
you had [INAUDIBLE],
you could overwrite
logs, or truncate log.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so we really want
to make sure that if something
goes wrong, the log, at least,
is intact.
So there's a separate
log file that
is only writable by this
uid, and all the log messages
are sent as RPCs to
this log service,
and even if everything else
gets compromised-- well,
except for okld-- then
the log is still intact,
because they talk about the
process of appending noise
to this log.
So what is this about?
Does this matter?
Should we worry
about this noise?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If somehow
you accidentally find
a way to read the log
and you can't see what
everyone else has been doing?
PROFESSOR: No, I think this
noise thing they are actually
worried about is that,
suppose you compromise
a service or you compromise
pubd or something,
you all of a sudden might
be able to write log
messages to the log,
and you can actually
write whatever you want
to the log at that point.
So the only guarantee they claim
to provide is that, I guess,
before the point of the
compromise, all the log entries
are intact, and afterwards
there is sort of legitimate log
entries interspersed
with whatever
else the attacker wants to log.
One actually cool thing about
having oklogd be a separate
process instead of it just
being an append-only file,
is that oklogd cannot add some
extra information to each log
entry, because you could imagine
maybe the operating system
supports an append-only file,
but then you don't actually
know who wrote anything
to a file, when that was,
whereas oklogd,
for every message,
it can actually maybe time
stamp it and say, actually,
I know this came from this
service, or this came from okd,
so you actually get extra
information in that log file
because it's a
separate service here.
Make sense?
So what's the point
of this okld guy?
Why do we need this guy
to be running as root?
I guess a couple reasons.
AUDIENCE: If you want no
one else to run as root,
then you need okld to
delegate who it is.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So someone needs to set up
this whole uid chroot thing,
and you need root for this
in Unix, so okld is it.
That's one reason.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: To define 80?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah, yeah.
This like whole listening
on a port business,
you have to bind on port 80, so
okld does that as well for us.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Complete to
open the log file oklogd.
You don't want to open oklogd
to have access to open the file.
You want to open
it for [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Maybe.
Actually, yeah.
I don't know.
I forget this from
the source code
whether they actually
do this or not.
You could imagine absolutley--
AUDIENCE: I think they write
it in the paper as well.
PROFESSOR: I see.
So okld opens the log
file and passes it in?
Could be.
AUDIENCE: Because
otherwise an attacker
that compromised oklogd would
be able to erase the entire log.
PROFESSOR: That's right, yeah.
So maybe you want to
open in append-only mode
and then pass it
to oklogd and then
you have more security
guarantees for the log.
Yeah, that's
actually pretty cool.
I missed that on the paper,
but makes a lot of sense, yeah.
Any other things
okld is doing for us?
I think that's basically it.
These are the main
things that you
can't do unless
you're root, and okld
is sort of the component
that ends up having
to do all these operations.
So I guess we had
this homework question
about what happens
if you leak this 20
byte database token thing.
So what do you guys think?
What's the damage?
Should we leak these guys?
Should we worry about it?
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: The
attacker can pretend
to be that specific
service [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right, yeah.
So, you might be able to
now connect and issue,
of course, all these
template queries.
That actually seems fairly
straightforward, I guess,
from this picture.
You probably need to compromise
one of these components
to be able to connect
to the database
server in the first place.
So I guess if you
have this token
and you manage to compromise one
of these pieces in the picture,
then you could run all
these queries as well.
Make sense?
Fairly straightforward stuff.
OK, I guess let's look
at, could you do better?
Could you do better
than this OKWS design?
Except for make this
whole argument about,
well, we might be able to do
even better, like allocating
a separate unit uid
per user in this design
instead of per service.
But here, every service, like
newsletters or friend matching
or account sign up
is a separate userid,
but every OKWS user isn't really
represented by a Unix uid.
There's not really userids,
they're service IDs.
So, would it make sense to have
different uids for every OKWS
customer?
Is there a reason for that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So at the moment,
if one user compromises
the service, then they can get
access to all the other user's
data for that same server.
PROFESSOR: That's right, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Whereas, if you
had a separate-- essentially
a separate service
and a separate dbproxy
for every user,
there's no way you
could access anyone
else's data either.
PROFESSOR: Right, but could it
be actually a stronger model?
So especially
for-- well, I guess
there's really two reasons why
I think the OKWS guys don't
go to that extreme model.
One of them is-- they make
a big deal in this paper--
is performance, right?
So if you have, I
don't know, a couple
million users on OkCupid,
then all of a sudden you
have a couple of million
processes running here,
or maybe a couple
million dbproxies,
or maybe you can optimize
something on the dbproxy side,
but here, yeah, you have
a couple million userids
and either you have a lot of
processes running all the time
or you're starting these
processes on demand.
And starting a process
involves some nontrivial amount
of overhead, so you
probably wouldn't
be able to get as good
of performance numbers
as these guys are able
to show with OKWS.
There's a performance argument.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
was just reading
in the paper that said the
performance of the system
was better than others?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How come?
PROFESSOR: Well, I think it's
partly because they fine tuned
their design to their particular
workload and it's also they
write their whole thing in C++.
The alternative is you're
writing some stuff in PHP,
then you're probably going
to win on that front.
It's also the case
that they don't
have nearly as many features
as, let's say, Apache has.
Apache has a very
general purpose design,
so it has lots of
processes running,
it restarts them
every once in awhile.
It actually has
every ttp connection
tying up a process for the
duration of that connection.
They do keep-alives.
That also increases the
number of processes you
have to run for their design.
So all those things
just add up in terms
of overhead for
Apache, because it
wants to handle
anything possibly
you could do with a web server.
Whereas these guys, I
think, are very specific.
We're just going to run these
services, very quick requests,
and no even static file
serving, if they can help it.
But I think there's actually
other web servers out there
these days that probably can
match the performance of OKWS
if you really wanted to.
So, for example, Nginx is
a very optimized web server
you can run these days.
If you want fast application
performance on the server side,
you probably want to keep a
long running process very much
like the OKWS service
thing, and the fast cgi
is a common mechanism,
or sort of protocol,
that you could use
on the server side
to implement this even in
Apache or Nginx as well.
So I think many of
these performance ideas
aren't exclusive to OKWS.
You couldn't perform the
same performance tricks
in other services as well.
They just show that
better security
doesn't preclude these tricks.
You could still get
the performance.
I guess for them, they were
just initially starting out
with an Apache-like
design, where
they were willing to pay the
price if it was easy to program
and secure, but it just
wasn't secure, so they said,
OK, well we'll do
this, and I don't
think the performance
was as necessarily
a big of a goal for them.
I guess they wanted to--
well, at the time they
had some problems in terms
of performance as well,
so I think they really
wanted good performance.
Any other questions
about this stuff?
OK.
So I guess it was
saying, one reason
why these guys don't want to
run a separate service per user
is the fact that there's
performance overheads
in doing that.
The other reason is that
their full application model
sort of hinges around a
service having to get access
to every user's data, like
finding your friends on OkCupid
or someone to go
out on a date with.
And as a result, this
per user isolation model
might not make a lot of sense,
because ultimately there
has to be a service that you're
going to send a request to,
and it's going to look
at everyone else's data
to find your match.
So that's probably, as a result,
not really amenable, like,
even if you had user IDs or
some sort of per user isolation
mechanism, you would
have to give that service
access to every userid anyway.
So for other services like
maybe Gmail or Dropbox,
where it's much
more user focused
and no sharing, then
a per user isolation
might make more sense
in terms of the benefits
you could get out of
it, because if there's
a userid on the Dropbox server
for every Dropbox customer,
then, well, there's a
process running for you
and there's a process
running for someone else,
and if you exploit
a bug, then you
can't touch other people's data.
But could be cool, I don't know.
Dropbox probably doesn't do
this for performance reasons,
but you could get
some security benefit.
Whereas, for OKWS guys, and
even functionality-wise,
they wouldn't be able
to take advantage
as much of this model.
So maybe for your
profile editing service,
maybe that could
be run per user,
but the matching thing
would still be shared.
Make sense?
All right.
So let's look at whether
OKWS actually manages
to improve security here.
So when we do think of whether
a system is secure or not
is to look at all the components
and see, well, first of all,
what's the attack surface?
Meaning, how would
you try to compromise
that component,
or how hard is it,
and second what's the damage?
So let's go through this list.
Let's start with okd, so
what's the attack surface?
What kinds of things could
you use to attack it?
[INAUDIBLE], like
all these requests
coming from the browser.
That seems pretty good.
You can control it
probably in lots of ways,
you can send lots
of strange input.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so maybe there is--
this thing is written in C++,
so probably these guys were
sloppy.
I think this guy's
a good programmer,
but if he was not very
careful somewhere,
could be easily exploitable.
So what's the damage?
Suppose you find a buffer
overflow or some other bug
in okd?
How bad is this?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You can call basically
any service on that machine?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK, so
you could call any service.
Is that bad?
How should we think of this?
AUDIENCE: You can call it
whatever input you want.
PROFESSOR: That's true, yeah.
But you could probably have done
that even without compromising,
because you can send any
http request you want,
which is basically what these
service requests end up being.
Maybe that's
actually not so bad.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could it route all the
traffic for maybe OK website?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That actually seems a
little more damaging, right?
You can all of a sudden
take over the whole website
and serve your pages
instead of sending
a request to the services.
You could redirect all
the people to match.com
or whoever else you
want to, I don't know.
I guess now they bought out
OkCupid but, before, who knows.
OK, anything else?
Could you leak data in any way?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, it
depends on, like if you
use any authentication in okd.
Instead of any SVC,
you could potentially
just do unauthorized requests,
like in the database?
PROFESSOR: Right.
In their case, this guy just
parses and forwards the request
on.
AUDIENCE: Could it [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Not only can you
redirect it first,
you could actually look for all
the subsequent requests, which
probably includes passwords
of other users connecting
to the site, and you
could save their passwords
or modify their requests
or see what they're doing
or fetch things on their behalf.
That seems damaging potentially.
That's probably
the biggest leak.
If you compromise okd, you can
probably watch other requests
and steal people's credential
passwords, steal their data
as it flows by.
Make sense?
AUDIENCE: Could you do some sort
of denial of service with just
with sending a whole--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so you could
probably chew up the CPU
or send lots of requests
to this, fill up database
with lots of data, but
that you could probably
do even by just sending lots
of requests in the first place.
So now [INAUDIBLE] are somewhat
complicated-- well, different.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So, the goal
here is not to leak data--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --from
different services.
If you have access to
okd, presumably you
could read the responses
that are being sent--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
So in fact, okd is has
to be pretty trustworthy,
because the responses don't
go directly back through okd
in the normal operation, because
you just pass off the fd,
and the service directly
writes to the fd.
But you could totally fake it
and create your own fd here.
So if you compromise
this, you could basically
watch all the traffic and
steal people's passwords there.
AUDIENCE: But, the other way--
PROFESSOR: And the response is--
AUDIENCE: --to the output, which
means that essentially you get
access--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Yeah, so you could--
If okd was compromised
and I happened to
log into that site,
you could probably
look at my responses
and you could probably
even take my password
and send other requests
with my credentials
and get data from there as well.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE:And then essentially
reconstruct the entire
database.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Yeah, or at least
for users who were
logged in at the time and
things you could reconstruct.
This is pretty damaging, right?
So this component is actually
a bit troublesome here.
What happens if we
compromise, let's say, oklogd?
How bad is that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
pretty bad.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so there's
like all this confidential data
in the log entries, then
that's probably not good,
but otherwise you can't probably
access the database directly,
right?
Pubd, I guess you might
corrupt templates, or something
like this, send out different
requests and responses, I mean.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So this
is about the logd.
Presumably okdlogd doesn't
have access to read the log.
It just needs--
PROFESSOR: Ah, yeah, yeah.
Good point.
Well, it depends on
how they do it, right?
If they really have
this append-only file,
then it might be that you
can't even read the log, so--
AUDIENCE: All you could
do is append garbage.
PROFESSOR:That's right, yeah.
So you could write
a lot of garbage,
but if they were using the OS
to enforce the append-only log,
and no reading, then
you might be actually
in good shape for
the log contents.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, I guess
also, you can not append.
So when a valid log comes in--
PROFESSOR: Right, so you could
probably block real entries,
fill it up with garbage.
You could also watch new entries
and at least compromise them.
AUDIENCE: Or if you're
relying on a rate
limit for number of logins.
PROFESSOR: That's right, yeah.
You could probably do that.
OK.
So what about the services?
That's, I think, their
main attack factor,
because-- actually, in most
of these systems, what you're
really worried about is
the one-off components,
because even in Apache,
the Apache code is probably
pretty good.
Like millions people
are running it,
everyone's looking
for bugs in it.
Probably [INAUDIBLE] not that
many bugs in Apache itself
or, well, even in SSL, for all
the hoopla we've heard recently
about [INAUDIBLE] and still
bugs probably not as bad
as the application code that
you write for a particular site,
because no one else
has reviewed that code.
You just wrote it,
you haven't really
tested it very thoroughly.
That's probably where most of
the bugs in a complex system
actually lie.
So the service code is probably
the equivalent for OKWS.
These components are
written by Max Krohn.
He was careful to make sure
there's no buffer overflows.
This component is written
by some web developer who
wants to deploy the next
feature as fast as possible,
so this is the part
where I think they really
worry about bugs being sort
of exploitable and potentially
damaging.
But hopefully the damage here
is not too big, in the sense
that you can only issue
whatever queries you are allowed
to do by the database proxy.
Make sense?
So what about okld?
This is a bit of
a sore thumb here.
It's, like, running as root.
How much should
we worry about it?
Of course, the damage is
pretty big if we compromise it.
You get access to everything
on the machine and all
the database proxy tokens.
How hard is it to
compromise okld?
What signals-- what
could you poke it with?
Does it take input?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] in
a very specific pattern.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so pretty
much the only input it takes
is when a child exits and
it gets a notification
that a child process
exited and then maybe it
responds it, or not,
if it is rate limited.
So if there's some
sort of erase condition
or a bug with handling
exactly-- it's
interesting-- lots of
exits at the same time,
then maybe you could
trigger something bad,
but even then it
seems hard to imagine
injecting some sort of shell
code through the exit pattern.
So it's probably a reasonable
thing to have to run as root,
because it doesn't take
a whole lot of input.
Make sense?
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: So presumably
a big concern
would be if you managed to
somehow exploit the dbproxy.
PROFESSOR: Uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: If it turns out
that it doesn't, like,
it provides an RPC
that's limited in scope,
but if there is some input you
can give that, that turns out
to run in different
query than it
was expecting to run,
presumably that could
be a big [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That could
be a bit of a problem.
So what's the attack vector
though on this database proxy?
I think you have to
have access to one
of these other components
in the first place.
So at least you have to
now compromise both--
you have to find a bug both in
the dbproxy and somewhere else,
so--
AUDIENCE: So not necessarily,
because the SVC is already
forwarding--
PROFESSOR: Right.
So as the SVC passes
through great query
is largely unchecked--
AUDIENCE: Well, so,
I mean, let's say
you're trying to log in, right?
It will pass.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, like your
Alice name goes in the template,
and yeah.
AUDIENCE: Alice is straight
to the dbproxy, in theory.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
So, there might be
some dbproxy bugs here
that are also exploitable.
Anyway, this hopefully
gives you guys
some sense of how do you
think of privileged separating
application.
And as we see, it's not perfect.
There are still many
things that could go wrong.
But it seems much better than
the nonprivileged separated
design that we started out with.